these are temporary bleachers needs to
accommodate a crowd of thousands the
line of traffic extends in both
directions as far as you can see
everything in the central area here in
Hollywood is being funneled toward the
Pantages Theater because this is Oscar
night
David rose and the orchestra supply the
rhythm at our cameras speak out the
familiar faces in our theater audiences
both Hollywood in New York on screen
we've had and review the honor roll of
tonight's Academy Awards Show the
nominees for distinguished achievement
in 1954
you
member
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences
mr. Charles Brackett
fellow members of the Academy gets
friends everywhere this is the last act
of the mystery play this is the night we
find out who walked away with the top
honors and if you have any fan blood in
your veins its pounding our
Pricewaterhouse our rough bound
accountants has all the answers in
tightly sealed envelopes Pricewaterhouse
also has permitted they sealed lips
secrecy is their trademark you won't
they're listening and we officials of
the Academy will learn the triumphant
names that precisely the same moment to
open these envelopes in the early part
of the program we have a group of
presenters picked by the whole industry
as the best of last year's performance
our 20 actor and actress nominees rather
than having them biting their nails and
wondering how they'll fare later on in
the evening we thought we'd give them
something to do and you a chance to see
them our front runners of the year we're
proud of them as we're proud of all our
nominees for 1954 a year of magnificent
screen achievements to act as master of
ceremonies we have a fellow who boasts
that he has Tufts and without but a foot
on tails tonight and stayed with us home
falls ladies and gentlemen mr. Bob Hope
Thank You Prez good evening ladies and
gentlemen welcome to you bet your career
Hollywood's biggest giveaway program and
I want you to know that the secret word
tonight is chefs I just want to know
this is the 27 Annual Academy Awards the
dramatic climax of a dynamic industry
whose motto is sick tempus ad hocs
chorus translated from the Latin means
those money in popcorn
perhaps you imagine people watching
don't realize the air of tension in this
theater tonight but five rivals for each
award or seated out there side by side
we're sitting on an ermine timebomb the
winner the winners will of course take
home an Oscar the losers will all be
presented with monogram do it yourself
suicide
and I have a word here for the losers if
it isn't whether you win or lose the
cops it's the way that you play the game
I found that embroidered on Stuart
Granger's cricket back though the
ostrich you know are made up specially
cheer that is that is the way it used to
be but they don't do that anymore now
they just wait and around the 1st of
March Walt Disney calls up the Academy
and says how many do you need but there
are a couple of new Awards this year
there is an award for the producer who
showed courage above and beyond the call
of duty by making a musical and regular
screen black and white and there's also
a special award for bravery for the
producer who made a picture without
Grace Kelly I thought
seriously I'm honored that I've chosen
this year to emcee these awards you know
helping hand out these Oscars give me
sort of an inner glow well it's more
than a glow I burn up two years ago I
received an honorary Oscar for a man of
my determination and honesty it was a
hollow victory
it really meant nothing as a matter of
fact I only keep the shrine open two
afternoons a week but it's wonderful
it's wonderful to have movies booming
again after the TV scare I was a little
worried last year when the Oscars came
through in a kneeling position but of
course the movies are now booming again
still television isn't worried and
they'll only start to worry when the
motion picture industry has enough money
to sponsor this program
anyway I want to say in the meantime
we've gathered here under one roof the
best stress most glamorous most talented
collection of automobile salesmen in the
world it's a very very dressy evening
there's mink as far as the eye can see
and as far as the eye can see
they are mink and I want to tell you
that 1954 was a big year in the movie
business that's the year the 20th
Century Fox lost Marilyn Monroe Darryl
zanuck stamped his foot so hard they
struck oil 1954 was a big year for
historical pictures that was the year
Tony Curtis captured all the countries
Errol Flynn missed in 1947 and the
studio's are really fighting for story
properties Sam Goldwyn got Guys and
Dolls Leland Hayward snatched up the old
man in the sea and this week Howard
Hughes bought the Yalta papers
now his only problem is to which of the
three parts Jane Russell will play but I
want this is the year of the big picture
Cecily DeMille is about to make the
eight commandments two of them he
couldn't get by the Breen office and
baby boy and Bing Crosby is up for an
Oscar for his wonderful portrayal of an
alcoholic
I knew if he hung around paramount long
enough he'd find the chandelier where
Ray Milland hid it and I think being did
a wonderful job as a drunk if he doesn't
win Old Crow ought to give him something
and we have some wonderful pictures up
for awards just look at them through
theatrical literature on the waterfront
the story of brutality and murder rear
window a starter of murder murder and
brutality with a country girl a story of
alcoholism Caine Mutiny a story of
insanity
whatever happened to seventh heaven I
think I figured out how to win the award
next year they're writing me part now I
play a psychopathic alcoholic naval
captain who wears lumberjack as flies
pigeons in the roof and has marooned on
a desert island with a guy named Friday
I can't
you know there may be a lot of tension
out here in Hollywood but things are
just as tense in the NBC century theater
in New York where a glamorous group of
nominees eagerly await the results of
the voting we take you to New York and
our mistress of ceremonies the lovely
Miss Thelma Ritter
thank you thank you and this is this is
the loveliness down the river hello
Hollywood
well Salma were loaded hearing with
stars in Hollywood I suppose you've got
an equally glittering turnout in New
York including everybody from the
legitimate theater to really the Truman
Capote doubt of his hammock I think
every actor and author in town is here
looks like a big shake-up miss Marilyn
Monroe though yes she just came in with
the brothers pal myself
we have farm olden Eva muri stained dark
agendas and across the former president
of the Academy
mr. Connor hey go come on these morons
I've gotta hope you like our magnificent
Hollywood set NBC has spared no pains or
expense to make it authentic the clouds
which I hope you can see in the
background represent smog how is the
blood pressure out west there Bob back
here in New York literally everybody is
sitting on pins and needles well del
melon I'll be right over the band-aids
hello everyone else both of their stages
representatives of the accounting firm
of Price Waterhouse here in Hollywood
mr. Bill Miller and in New York mr. Ward
Ogden
in the sealed envelopes these gentlemen
hold our such tremendous secrets the
three times we have to postpone these
ceremonies because the wind wasn't right
first awards are for documentary films
to present them one of Hollywood's most
beautiful actresses miss Grace Kelly
the documentary short subjects the
winner is Thursday's children more films
the heart of most films and worldwide
pictures I'm happy and proud to receive
this award thank you
the documentary features the winner is
the vanishing prairie
on behalf of all the people who play
such an important part in bringing these
to the screen I thank you
oh those doorstops say grace a pretty
girl like you how do you find time I
just want to ask you one thing how do
you find time to make so many pictures
you know you shouldn't work so hard Oh
Bom you should talk why for a fella
who's retired from television well I
have a deal with betty hutton you see
she retires one month and I retired and
I say you know growl Judy Garland was
supposed to be here to help you present
these awards tonight grace but due to
circumstances beyond her control she
didn't make it have you heard how she is
she's fine Bob and her only regret is
that she can't be with us here tonight
well after all we didn't expect her to
act out a star is born right here on the
stage
he's coming
you